hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Collina cool
ina : ah I have no idea I'm gonna guess
it's Kalina but this is a Portuguese
made game if you couldn't tell by the
language option choices here that we are
gonna get into right now Hill a common
name a comment where where we going wow
wow wow we're flying through the woods
that's what I thought as I climbed that
place tonight with my parents watch this
case up what this'll be a deal that was
real spice uh-huh okay since obviously I
do not speak Portuguese I do not
understand why my grandmother lived
there alone the nearest place with any
sign of civilization was a small village
that existed at the base of the hill
even knowing this when my parents wanted
lowland areas in the head of that visit
it there was nothing that made them quit
not that I did not like her I just did
not like the place it was boring there
was nothing to do even mobile and
Internet work there not to mention that
this place sometimes gave me a little
afraid will you be everything went well
like all the previous times we would
visit it is went well until we get there
yeah there was nothing there total
darkness luckily my dad always had a
flashlight in the glove box walked
inside the house and that's when it
happiness you know hope you're enjoying
ah live translations that are going on
right now why God run the Piranha that's
when I felt something pushing me in a
closet oh my it was my father he just
told you to run why would he push you in
a closet
run run inside our run stay there but
run run in place okay
anyway tip cover the lantern to handle
it hor
hover over the lantern I can barely see
a ding dong damn thing okay anyway that
was okay all right it's gonna be like
that eh
so uh oh there we go take the batteries
to recharge the light okay so this game
is gonna be a little different than I
anticipated it's awfully dark hope you
guys didn't mind the awkwardness of me
trying to read over that guy's voice
okay take the batteries with my grasping
a hand
okay we're full up on batteries hurrah
hurrah as all forever I don't see why
Heron toast didn't just run us out the
door whatever not gonna question the
logic of this scaredy-cat baby parents
what's all this then reach out with my
my hand they are appearing more
frequently everyday that is no longer
now no longer know the to do to send
them although I lost my amulet that kept
them apart near the lamp in the room
guests as he ran oh gosh oh goodness oh
dear it's gonna be okay oh no is it just
gonna be loud clanging noises that you
throw things in front of my face is
hella it's gonna be because I am rapidly
getting out of the mood
okay dramatic miss miss miss okay
whatever all right let's try to take
this seriously because supposedly this
is very scary I need to take it
seriously in order to be a mother it
would help if the noise is sounded in
any way realistic my a Mila was not
there he was gone I think they are
somehow able to realize their attendance
that night while sleeping I felt
something touching me
God scared there was nothing period if
this is really true then we'll be in our
plan completely I heard a horrible noise
in the room dinner but have not had the
courage to verify that it was as if
we're throwing things on the walls
surely they are again whoo all right I
read a readout right let's find out
what's going on here
besides loud noises this is gonna be
ridiculous isn't it if I really I you
know what I go into these games I
legitimately hope that they can scare me
with sometimes it does not work but I am
NOT gonna give up on this game I'm gonna
give it a few more chances to give me
the heebie will ease the GB will ease
the heebie-jeebies the G B D B's I don't
know how now is someone there is someone
hiding in the darkness I must comment it
is the worst flashlight I've ever seen
in the game ever ever ever ever ever can
I touch this radio with my mine
and also I don't like the way there are
white dots around objects that's really
weird no clue what that's all about
Lala hello is there someone waiting for
you in your closet alright bye Joe okay
he's right behind you
don't look at him but then he'll really
be mad okay so anyway I see a glowy
thing in here more white dot äj--
that's cool I don't even know if you
guys will be able to see the white dots
that I see but I see them all over the
place seems like they tried to put too
high resolution models or something's
going on with the way the models
interact with the environment but the
draw finder or the view distance I don't
know I'm not an expert on this thing
these things I don't know all I know is
that they didn't no no okey-dokey
all right fire hey you burned my note
they are already among us I just see a
passing them to the kitchen they seem
uncomfortable with my presence here I
heard a whisper as soon as I saw one of
those beings passing he said there is no
escape you will not be suspected perdona
ja that is was the reason that this was
the reason but now I'm sure are
certainly wanting to see me through
burnt okey-dokey
so far this seems to be another exercise
for my voice so I'm going to act as if I
am this person in this house
well who know I'm just a little
Portuguese teenager kid I don't know how
old I am who do my mommy and daddies are
dead those are geared and pheenoh thank
you I'm uh oh thank you flowers yes I
know
incredible performance that that was
it'll be Evan here a bathroom anything
weird happening in the bathroom
a rubber tub rub-a-dub-dub give me a
scrub anybody gonna help me out in this
tub nope okay fine
oh no I thought I got stuck in there for
a second alright so far I see exactly
nothing which is totally awesome
anything behind the door nope open the
door get on the floor everybody do the
dinosaur okay
enough silliness time to take this
seriously hos ooh really it's a really
time to take it seriously it's out what
time it is is that what it is okay
anyway so I don't know what else it
expects to throw at me don't think I've
been here yet have I
well yes I have cuz there's the radio
this is where are you all are gonna
remember that there's something waiting
right behind you it's literally standing
right behind you can you feel its breath
on your neck oh no way did I go this way
yeah I'm it wait a minute to be another
way that I haven't gone it's just too
damn dark I can't see where the hallways
are probably you guys aren't gonna
notice because if if I ever say in game
it's too damn dark I can't see a
bleeding bloody thing that me and you
guys can see a bleedy bloody thing that
means I bumped up the brightness for you
you're welcome
I've been here too I remember this is a
stupid bedroom a been here done this how
do I get out Squiggy Squiggy I guess I
didn't do that I remember seeing that
though maybe I don't maybe I don't
remember maybe that's just another way
to go whoa
Oh where'd that come from is some scary
gonna happen I hear a dripping I didn't
hear a dripping before why suddenly now
Oh is there someone there waiting for me
in the darkness I would SPECT not but
considering the drippy drop he said I
hear I would assume that they're coming
from either the kitchen sink or from the
bathroom hello drippy drop II know all
right
oh here's a note that I missed all
righty then my god
actually the reason was I imagined that
as it is possible how can they come back
for that I thought they were all
finished I need help the only person I
in I trust to ask for help is my
daughter oh my girl I hope the phone
that is right side of the radios
operating today phone right side of the
radio is that a clue hello okay so I
need to redo my persona Jub a little
girl now I'm not even gonna bother you
don't be afraid you guys probably don't
want to hear that you guys proud you you
wouldn't want to hear me interpret a
little girl yeah I'd just be weird
some of you sickos out there probably do
okay anyway so phone
okay that was actually a good one oh
that's a pretty good so there's no phone
here my phone is gone if they ever get
I'm done doing this certainly since can
take me should only be kidding me
just as I did with them one day I'm
getting agonized I heard several voices
calling me to the bathroom I felt that
my end is coming so my end is waiting
for me in the bathroom so what you're
trying to say is that what you are
trying to tell me whoa hello hi there
hey how's it going hey don't bring good
you look so good you look a little pale
fudge off f off and go to hell hello hi
how are you doing my name is Wilbur oh
no wait I'm a girl my name is Abigail
I'm a pretty girl don't tell me I'm not
hi how's it going doing good don't break
up you've been doing those trunk
rotations okay whew blood blood
everywhere
this is good it's gonna be real good I
just talked to one of them I'm sorry for
what I did it was a disease something
that could not control when saw that
expression on their faces was elated and
excited so I made her want more and more
now they're here to take revenge from me
what I understand that is my end I lost
my door key for luckily my spare keys in
the desk in my rent a motorized carpet
or a sequence woven on TV toda so Sierra
says decimal gas 0gz Mars para pagar
pasa screams hilarity Missoula do
Essam Lana Coolio Tomita moko Mead Eldar
para de mere town de comida esta noche
hasta Mia Viejo chapattis Oh Lea Ferran
L yo Apogee economy de policía es table
appears Adachi agree t oz knee-deep
watch a movie
hola mijo pues la cabeza storm XE short
order atomizer body bore my 0 qu qu of
Elysee Chopra's infos you okay no food I
was not the only one was many others a
modulation now the Koreans for certain
brands of all masses chamula tyranny
protection de salmonela no sé cómo es la
bolita no capitation again yo Sara Paris
pada Zaman ZT video kg boo
hahaha l Sophie oh okay alright then
what hi friend how are you good great
what uh tester me oh no I'm so scared a
herp a derp oh no oh no I fell down
actually that is kind of worrisome okay
this is really dark and I'm almost out
of battle well okay then
jeez for being dead people you see
certainly seem to be having a good time
okay I can't see a blini bloody thing I
highly doubt that you guys can see a
bleeding lady thing either so I'm just
gonna wander in the darkness trying to
follow the walls wherever they may lead
oh and I going up what just happen did I
go up or did not did I not what happened
where am i where am I now
I can't see anything
what the hell okay Hey look I'm outside
did I escape did I I'm gonna run
whoo-hoo-hoo-ha right no right right let
me running right look I did nothing I
realized a lesson by women who by this
high run everybody stopped making follow
me that's high run I can't run like
normal people I do I run very strangely
okay that's how I run what what what all
right I fell and died broke my neck
goody
hahaha well okay that was interesting
hmm hmm it wasn't awful I'll give it
that there was some work put into it
there was definitely some work put into
it but just the low quality of the sound
is really what got to me because I've
said it before sound in a horror game is
so so so important you can throw as many
job scares as you want you can throw as
much dark hallways you can make it pitch
black
don't matter if the sound isn't there or
even if the sound isn't there if it's
total silence
that's unnerving because it's unnatural
sometimes when you sparingly but the
cheapo sound effects for the jumps just
kind of threw me off right off right off
the bat and and it was just
it was a lot of work put into it I don't
want to put down the developer but there
was a lot of things you could have done
better I'll leave it at that
that's all say so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and to make
sure that this video is in a total waste
here's what you've all been waiting for
here
yeah
Oh
okay
oh those my teddy fine
but
dear mother with a go to your mother was
your
because one or the other